revenons maintenant sur cette épidémie
des bola qui fait des ravages en Afrique
de l'Ouest et qui soulève de plus en
plus de crainte en Occident alors où en
est-on les autorités médicales
canadiennes sont-elles prêtes j'ai avec
moi un régime Laurent de la Fédération
interprofessionnelle de la santé du
Québec et le microbiologiste Richard
marchand bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir Je
vous propose qu'on regarde ensemble un
reportage de mon collègue de l'émission
Découverte d'Annie Lemieux qui nous
rappelle ce qu'est ce fameux virus et
comment il peut se propager on regarde
ça
les premiers cas sont survenus à la
suite de la manipulation d'animaux
infectés comme les chauves-souris ou les
singes
chez l'humain les bolas ne s'attrapent
pas par voie aérienne contrairement la
grippe le principal mode de transmission
est le contact direct avec les fluides
biologiques d'une personne infectée
notamment le sang et les vomissures
la salive les larmes et la sueur sont
des vecteurs de moindre importance
pour que l'infection se propage il faut
absolument que le sang ou les vomissures
du malade entre en contact avec les
muqueuses ou la plaie le nouvel hôte
après la mort le virus survit dans le
sang de sa victime pendant des semaines
le cadavre reste donc contagieux
sur les surfaces contaminées
l'équipement médical et la literie la
survie des bolas est courte quelques
heures tout au plus les risques de
contagion indirect demeurent donc très
bas
en ce moment le taux de transmission du
virus varie d'un pays à l'autre par
exemple en Sierra Leone chaque victime
en contamine deux autres en
épidémiologie ce niveau de transmission
est relativement faible dans le cas de
la rougeole on note que chaque malade
infectra 18 autres personnes
pour que l'épidémie débola se résorbe
chaque nouvelle victime devra
nécessairement en contaminer moins d'une
autre
l'OMS annoncera la fin de l'épidémie
lorsque aucun cas ne sera répertorié
pendant 42 jours soit deux fois la
période d'incubation du virus nous
sommes encore bien loin d'une telle
annonce ici Dani Lemieux ras au Canada
Montréal
ouais on est encore loin d'une telle
annonce alors on voit que dans ce
reportage que finalement le virus Ébola
ne se transmet pas si facilement que ça
alors on peut se demander comment il se
fait qu'aux États-Unis qui est pourtant
la fine pointe sur le plan médical qui
si bien équipé n'a pas réussi à contenir
quoi la propagation du virus docteur
marchand comment ça se fait ceci du
virus pour contrôler un virus qu'on
appelle de niveau 4 en terme de risque
d'enjorosité il y a trois conditions il
faut l'équipement approprié il faut un
entraînement approprié parce que c'est
pas juste c'est pas juste d'avoir cet
équipement là il faut être formé
entraîner et entraîner et entraîner pour
être capable de s'en servir parce que
toute petite erreur toute petite
manipulation de inadéquate peut être
fatale en fait ça prend un entraînement
de type quasi militaire ou même
militaire franc et la troisième
condition ça prend un système de
commandement fonctionnel efficace à
l'intérieur du système qui assure la
surveillance et les soins alors est-ce
que nous on aurait fait mieux qu'aux
États-Unis s'il y avait eu un cas où
chez nous je passe certaines du tout on
est quand même mieux qu'aux États-Unis
mais il y a des choses qu'on a apprises
aujourd'hui avec avec la conférence des
infirmières de des États-Unis entre
autres et durée du Canada moi j'étais
certaine qu'aux États-Unis qui avait
déjà un protocole tout le monde était
prêt et j'ai appris que c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai quand je leur disais on
leur demandait mais pourquoi est-ce que
c'est quoi on entend qu'il y a eu une
brisure dans l'achat il y en avait pas
de protocole un en plus il y a des
hôpitaux privés qui ont acheté les gants
les plus chips qui se déchaînent
c'est ça et quand on parle d'équipement
c'est que c'est faux que ça soit
équipement vraiment adapté à chaque
personne l'équipement pour Monsieur ça
me va pas moi le masque donc il faut il
faut avoir ça il faut que ce soit adapté
à chaque personne et non pas être en
train de taper comme elles nous ont
raconté aujourd'hui alors c'est pour ça
que on dit au Québec on a le temps en
faisant de façon pressée mais on a le
temps de faire les choses à dire de
faire de la formation de s'assurer qu'on
a l'équipement que tout le monde a un
équipement et qu'on a la formation dont
vous parliez
qui dit qu'il y a 85% des infirmières
qui disent ne pas avoir reçu aucune
formation je dois même pas la moindre la
moindre indication la sur ce qu'elle
doit faire j'aurais mis ça en doute hier
mais après la conférence de cet
après-midi je n'en doute plus bon là
vous dites ça prend la formation mais
comment dans les hôpitaux en ce moment
les infirmières n'ont pas eu cette
formation elles n'ont pas eu cette
formation et elles sont très inquiète
parce qu'elles disent il y a aucun temps
mort en ce moment dans les
établissements tout le monde on ne
travaille tout le temps tout le temps
pendant les 8 heures ou 12 heures qu'on
est là donc elles disent mais oui j'ai
vu un papier mais un papier ça veut pas
dire que j'ai la formation la formation
d'un équipement il faut l'essayer il
faut le tester il faut l'enlever et il
faut s'assurer qui est des équipes
dédiées des équipes miroirs comme on dit
donc il va surveiller comment je
l'enlève comment je le mets on n'a pas
ça en ce moment au Québec dans tous les
établissements de santé de Cardi est-ce
que vous avez eu des simulations est-ce
que on a fait des on a fait des
simulations en fait sur papier tout le
monde est prêt semble-t-il si on suit au
message qu'on nous dit mais dans la
réalité sur le terrain cette formation
ces entraînements répétés ont lieu ont
pas eu lieu dans la majorité des
établissements sauf peut-être les
centres dédiés alors donc deux options
c'est les deux hôpitaux ornent nos
essais nous autres ont démontré par
exemple au niveau de nos infirmières en
prévention des infections que pas
habitué à manipuler ce genre d'uniformes
de protection mais ce contaminer
elle-même dès le début et ça prend deux
trois quatre cinq six répétitions avant
d'être capable de se protéger de façon
adéquate sans se contaminée c'était la
même chose au laboratoire aussi où on a
on a mis en place des simulations donc
il faut faire cet entraînement c'est
comme pour le militaire il faut
entraîner les soldats des réservistes à
répéter des gestes de façon régulière
pour être capable de le faire alors pour
faire cet entraînement il faut libérer
les personnes il faut organiser le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital il faut le
budget et il faut les budget
actuellement les budgets ne sont pas
libérés on laisse chaque hôpital dans le
contexte des coupures actuelles ou
actuels on cherche à tout éliminer et on
n'a pas défini ce qu'il faut pour que
les bottines suivent les babines puis
moi la réalité et la théorie et la
réalité ça fait ça fait quand même
plusieurs jours qu'on en parle et que on
exprime les inquiétudes différentes
façons moi je pense que c'est assez moi
je pense qu'on est rendu où la santé
publique devrait faire un exercice de
communication réelle dire à la
population voici xnomes de
professionnels en première ligne on a
autant d'équipements les voici pour ce
monde-là voici comment on va faire voici
le programme de formation que tous les
établissements vont devoir appliquer on
va libérer des gens en combien de temps
etc bon après ça au moins on va être
capable de savoir vers quoi on s'en va
réellement et là on nous demande le
marché avec la foi ça marche pas dit il
y a des protocoles il y a des mesures
tout est en place on est sur papier il
n'y a pas de protocole ils sont là sur
papier maintenant il faut travailler
avec ces protocoles qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire s'assurer que on va voir le
soutien clinique 24 heures par jour si
un coffre présente je sais pas moi sur
la réussite de Montréal à 1h du matin il
faut savoir qui dans l'établissement
prend cette responsabilité qui sera mon
soutien clinique qui va s'organiser pour
avoir immédiatement le mettre en
isolation qui va me dire effectivement
j'ai l'équipement parce qu'en ce moment
ce que ce que sur le terrain disent mais
je sais même pas où est l'équipement
s'il y en a un je sais pas je l'ai pas
vu on me l'a pas montré c'est pas normal
vous vous dites il faut l'essayer il
faut faut prendre la banque pour
l'intégrer en fait après la bonne
équipement ça prend un bon entraînement
et ça prend une ligne de commandement
alors l'air précise et efficace et c'est
ça et ça prend le budget qui va avec
parce que s'il y a pas de budget il y a
rien qui se fait non non là on est dans
les structures avec les autres on veut
les structures pour un moment puis
mettons l'accent sur la formation
là-dessus est-ce que je me trompe ou on
sent une plus grande inquiétude de la
part du du corps médical face à cette
épidémie par rapport peut-être à
d'autres épidémies
l'anxiété augmente l'inquiétude augmente
plus on nous dit que tout est là fait
quand on se rend compte que tout est pas
là mais c'est sûr que l'inquiétude
augmente parce qu'on sait que c'est pas
tout à fait exact alors quand on nous
dit oui tout est là tout est correct
alors on se dit ben ça arrivera pas donc
ça ne changera pas donc je vais rester
dans l'inquiétude parce que c'est quand
même le personnel médical qui est le
plus touché quand on regarde ce qui
s'est passé en Afrique et quand on
regarde ce qui se passe maintenant en
Occident c'est j'ai plusieurs confrères
qui se disent et concerts qui se disent
pas trop inquiet parce qu'ils sont à peu
près convaincus que ceux qui connaissent
des techniques d'isolement et
satisfaisant et adéquat or ceux qui sont
rassurés c'est parce qu'ils ont jamais
en général travailler avec ce genre de
microbes parce que ceux qui ont
travaillé avec des micro-organismes
aussi dangereux que niveau 4 sont en
général pour assurer du tout certains
craignent aussi une mutation du virus
docteur marchand est-ce que c'est
possible tout est possible de
transmettre de façon aérienne ça est-ce
que c'est une possibilité ou non c'est
peu probable dans ce modèle celle de
virus là mais tout est possible avec la
biologie ça faut savoir que la nature
trouve toujours un chemin pour amener de
grands changements il y a toujours eu
des épidémies à tous les 50 ans qui
éliminait 10 à 15% de la population de
la planète nous on est dû depuis une
trentaine d'années un jour il va en
avoir une c'est à peu près certain mais
en même temps il y a quand même assez
peu de cas là pour le moment en Occident
est-ce qu'on est en train d'exagérer
toute cette affaire là non on exagère
pas on demande juste d'être préparé si
le cas arrive dans trois jours ou dans
une semaine il faut déjà être préparé
c'est juste ça c'est sûr faire de la
prévention et c'est ça empêcher que ça
se propage
docteur marchand malheureusement c'est
tout le temps qu'il nous reste merci
beaucoup voulu ajouter quelque chose et
si c'est pas les beaux là ça sera la
grippe aviaire ça sera un autre virus
donc il faut se préparer et pour tous
les virus possibles merci beaucoup à
vous deux merci merci
belle-soeur de Michel Tremblay revisitée
pour ses 50 ans de pièces de théâtre en
joie à comédie musicale en anglais c'est
après la pause au Téléjournal